[Music]
not the mama nude not the mama
oh no hail the daddy yes they were doing
you are not the mom I don't think so it
was always dad right
well comes out of the vagina but I see
what you're getting at no I'm saying I
just think we need more equality you are
but it came from my yeah but you think
we need more quality David oppa I
questioned I questioned pike up he was
mine when he was first born he was
sought chengqi yeah I get that ball was
chick that phone was a thousand percent
Chinese when he came out here he came
out with the little red hat and
everything as well that falls eyes are
like all the way down here when they
took I think I thought that maybe like
just like first foot second oh they did
they switch my baby and I was like no
that's him you could tell by his face I
know but it was when he was first first
first mass you can find pictures you
could tell from it's not about the
purple one where he's like a purple
alien but it was still purple it was a
purple of great if though do you come
out with like Harry Potter you don't see
him like that that was like the moment
they took them out do the c-section by
the time I saw him he cleaned up do you
look so innocent coming out because the
kid has the most innocent face I've ever
seen give you a perfect bank robber yeah
exactly that me sir the mother of a girl
who was kidnapped 20 years ago wishes
her daughter was never found
wow that is [ __ ] shame why holy balls
because her wish you wish you've got
reunited with their daughters who's a
bad she's a [ __ ]
she's like we have nothing in common oh
that's right you can't tell who the [ __ ]
oh that's right the probably a little
like you changed oh damn is that what
happened the mom named Shannara and the
daughter named Kamiya coming at a point
she's got a nose piercing his giant
cursors just occurs interesting that her
that inside of her nose pierced
kids yeah like that's next level what do
you call it the [ __ ] tell both of
them it was like a one sided septum so
pretty much
Kamiya was kidnapped when she was only a
few hours old from the hospital hours Oh
kidnap kids it's like kidnapping a
headache I don't get that [ __ ] yeah Tyco
got to [ __ ] uh ankle alarm thingies
like it's if you get to because that's
how how often it happens so that way you
have to take both of them off if you
want to
[ __ ] holy cow you think you
would only need one but they have two of
them on his ankles just in case as a mom
might be pissed cuz she get that [ __ ]
person is a freebie like you ought to
[ __ ] just take this [ __ ] parasite
in your stomach for nine [ __ ] months
and if somebody just takes what the [ __ ]
yeah so the woman that kidnapped her was
an his named Gloria and so Gloria
apparently had a miscarriage and she was
so like so she was at the hospital and
then no like she planned she planned to
kidnap a baby because she has I was like
damn what if she was at the hospital and
she's like she's in the gown she's like
she [ __ ] had a miscarriage and did
you like no I did it that's my baby and
she [ __ ] grabbed the baby and ran
away cuz I saw that in the movie well
this is real life all right
but I bet you that's how it happens but
this one she ended up having a
miscarriage and she dressed like a nurse
went into the room where she just had
the baby and she told her like oh we
need to take her away to get some checks
and then what if she was stupid as [ __ ]
and she bought like those sexy nurse
outfits for Halloween and she walked
around the hospital like in disguise and
[ __ ] and everyone else is stupid cuz she
got away we gotta take her cuz we gotta
get her some checks it's payday so they
actually spend five hours together so
they had four and then that's when she
got taken away - you took for a fever
and then she didn't see her until 18
years apparently by the time they found
the baby there was no hope
girl did she get the group here so sorry
basket oh yeah like what is that you
know what some chocolate eggs in it this
was back in 1998 and so when the police
arrived they were blaming the mom
oh what'd you do with the baby did you
sell the baby you did something than the
baby like what the [ __ ] that was the
trend at the hospital damn Wow
apparently they followed like 2,000
leads all the way to Nova Scotia I like
just everywhere and you talk about the
worst leads on earth NOAA Scotia she's
in Nova Scotia hope that helps you know
she's a young black girl she was born in
Florida but she ended up being
in South Carolina as alexis was her name
that Gloria gave her and so after they
were found apparently
Kamiya she found out a year and a half
earlier that she was the baby from Ana
abduct like she was abducted as a baby
but she decided not to say anything and
in fact she even told Gloria you know
what if they ever find out like run like
don't get caught her mom now yeah that's
her mom like she raised her and so but
now maybe she had a great childhood she
probably did cuz I'll [ __ ] it and use
that power over my kidnapper I'll be
like you're not gonna buy me donas [ __ ]
well I'll tell the police you kidnapped
me
oh that's true yeah but then it's like
oh you so cool you know what my real
parents are polly garbage yeah you don't
give me money for grad night I'll tell
the cops yep easy Dan yeah but she's got
gave her the world and she's like magic
the best mom ever
[ __ ] man even though I know you're not
my mom I want you to be a hundred
percent it's cuz kids need leverage over
their parents yeah that's the ultimate
leverage you could only have a good
childhood if you'd have to make all the
choices if I could control my parents
and my love for them would be way bigger
all right I'm going to show you guys a
video clip of my mom being interviewed
and claiming why now she beats her ass
she never found so I feel alone it's no
winning situation I don't have a
relationship with my child right now
speaking as his woman so yeah I still
know so wicked I got nothing I just wish
she wouldn't ever get back to religion
because my baby back this one made a
mockery of my life when she took my baby
and not only did you make a mockery when
you brought my baby back but you let her
help you make a mockery of my look and
this Church of Our Lady to keep reaching
out to my town every day so she still
committing a crime and you had the right
to stop dating you did not so no I don't
have no respect for each other I don't
and no I'm not celebrating my 20th
birthday this is the second Mother's Day
I didn't get a text I didn't get a call
I didn't get a car
nothing so no I'm not celebrating her
20th birthday she even blocked her
daughter on her phone so she's because
she's like
disrespect because they they did try to
connect but then it was just a horrible
relationship that happened because of
the of Gloria being involved in this
girl's walking with their head so yeah
she is and so it's a [ __ ] yeah so
the mom she ended up having four more
kids after five years after she was
kidnapped she had stolen any more kids
and so now she's saying that her kid her
older kids are on Facebook or online
like defending the mom because a lot of
people are on the kidnappers side
warrior side well I that's what they're
reporting that's crazy you know am I
scared to what's the argument yeah at
the end of the day who committed the
first big crime the kidnapper none of
this [ __ ] would have happened if the
[ __ ] kidnapper never came the mom
committed no crimes well I mean I get it
cuz the the masses they don't critically
think so for them they're like how can a
mall I'm like now you have your daughter
or like how can you just like shun
you're like you know turn your back on
her now like she's your daughter she's
powerless but like biologically your
daughter but it's like geez they were
[ __ ] stupid yeah she's joy she's
Gloria's daughter um
but do the masses I can see if she's a
burglars daughter dog that's the problem
yeah I mean I don't know I don't know
what what the whole situation is like I
don't know if Gloria is like harassing
the mom now like yeah she might be back
in your life but she stole mine or
whatever I don't know that so another
part of me is also like damn though like
if my kid was taken away from me and I
have a chance to like connect somehow
like maybe I would be friends or
something I mean I don't know cuz at
this point they're complete strangers a
relationship yeah it's a hard place she
still wants to be she still goes as
Alexis like she never yeah because it's
like she made closure and maybe she
moved on but then this came back so it's
like a double [ __ ] that's what I got
from the interview it's because she did
end up getting a 1.2 million
our settlement from the hospital because
of their like has the nice house a nice
house see now it all makes sense well
she did buy a house but she lost it to
foreclosure with that money and she was
also helping people around her so it's
like the lottery thing yeah yeah and
everyone sticks a hand out 1998 1.2 mil
there's a lot in floor it happened in
1988 yeah yeah but we don't know when
she got the money cuz it could have been
a long court case
yeah they don't tell me when she exactly
how does Gloria Peng like how come she
doesn't get [ __ ] arrested or what did
she did she's in jail she's serving 18
years how she still reach out all the
time because the judge allowed it the
judge is still allowing for the daughter
that's why the die get that to that okay
that wasn't that was a piece though feel
like I needed to know cuz that helps me
understand a little bit better cuz cuz
yeah if your she's in jail at least
that's time yo she is and then that's
why this mom is really upset because the
daughter sent to mother's day cars to
the woman in jail and none and oh by the
way I forgot to mention the reason why
she says she's not celebrating her
birthday was because since she got
kidnapped every single year on her
birthday she always bought a cake and
she cut out a slice for her and they
should cut out a slice for their
daughter and left it in the freezer and
every year she kept accumulating slices
a cake she was hoping to find her but
then for these last two years or I guess
this year she's not going to so she's
always been on her mind always know that
the whole time the daughter's just like
[ __ ] e and she's like I always thought
we would one day get together and eat a
bunch of old frozen cake I'm not taking
from me how could you
looks like anniversary cake you guys do
that with your with your wedding cake no
yeah we didn't either
do we even have a wedding you know we
now what are you but the you know the
mom should be a little understanding
though cuz the kidnapped daughter had
nothing to do with this and she grew up
20 years with this woman
I agree [ __ ] she knows no other love
it's it's it's like why do you expect
her all of a sudden go I knew it I agree
very selfish very selfishly yeah she's
only sing like everything she's gone
through she doesn't realize it the
daughter yeah and for her to expect like
where's my Mother's Day card [ __ ] she
doesn't know you what she tried to
establish that relationship man like
that I think that's what but she's still
a stranger stranger I mean you know when
you're you're a kid have you ever met
people like when you're kids and there's
a baby they go I remember you so much
you're like who the [ __ ] are you
remember when we used to shut the [ __ ]
up don't touch me anymore you know like
no I know what he's tired baby I know
what I'm not - but the way he worded it
I just pictured bowl-cut baby Joe yeah
don't [ __ ] touch me bro yes that
doesn't come out in here you know baby
but that's why it laughed because I
pictured bowl-cut Joe literally seeing
it you had me at Booker Joe
[Applause]
[Music]